hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
weltweite gibt ein leckeres bisher uns
war mario cupcakes und die capex gehen
ziemlich schnell sind sehr einfach aber
dennoch geschmacklich ein richtig tolles
erlebnis würde ich mal sagen und ich
statt jetzt direkt mit den muffins ich
habe mir jetzt hier auch schon mal die
papier förmchen gerichtet und zwar nehme
ich jetzt heute diese süßen cupcake
förmchen und die sind jetzt etwas
kleiner
also so von der größe her sind so wie
normale muffin förmchen und ich zeige
euch jetzt mal kurz die zutaten also ich
brauch 150 g weiche butter 150 gramm
zucker etwas von exakt natürlich eines
lesesaals zweier diesem zimmer waren 160
gramm mehl 30 gramm kakaopulver denn ich
möchte schokoladig haben etwas milch da
weiß ich noch nicht genau wie viel wir
brauchen einfach nur so ein schluck
wahrscheinlich dann einen halben
teelöffel backpulver und vierten
telefonaten und ich habe hier noch oreo
kekse und zwar ist das zum ganzes
päckchen gewesen und ich brauche jetzt
gleich zwölf stück jetzt bereite ich
zuerst mal den teig zu
und da ist auch wirklich wichtig dass
alle zutaten zimmer wahnsinn
damit sich der rührteig eben gut
verbindet jetzt kommt zuerst die butter
in die rührschüssel ihr könnt da auch
gerne handwerk gerät dafür benutzen dann
einfach mit dem schneebesen aber wenn
ihr mit einer küchenmaschine arbeitet
dann auf jeden fall sondern flach hörer
benutzen
hier gebe ich jetzt noch die prise salz
und rein
und vanille und dior kaffee tee oder
kekse sind ja sowieso mit
vanillegeschmack deswegen muss natürlich
auch etwas vanille in den teig mit rein
sony-kunden zutat
das ist ja bei mir eine grundzutat genau
dann noch der poker mit rein und jetzt
wird es so etwa drei minuten cremig
gerührt
und wenn sich dann alles schön verbunden
hat dann kommen die eier mit rein
manchmal passiert dass der hörer die
maße so ein bisschen hoch drückt dann
geht einfach einem teig sauber rein und
drückt sie wieder runter das ist gar
nicht schlimm
und jetzt gebe ich die eier nach und
nach dazu dass jedes ei so etwa eine
halbe minute einrühren
damit die masse eben schön homogen wird
und jetzt muss ich hier noch die
trockenen zutaten also kakaopulver mehl
backpulver und natron und wenn ihr kein
natrium hab da einfach noch ein bisschen
bei pulver für ich jetzt kurz da wird
sich das backpulver eines natron schönen
mit dem mehl verbindet
und dann kommt es direkt mit zum teil
jetzt wird es bei mittlerer stufe kurz
eingerückt und jetzt nehmen wir nur so
viel milch das eben ein schöner klapper
teig entsteht denn nicht zu fest aber
auch nicht so flüssig ist kleine ella
meldet sich
der teig ist jetzt fertig und diente die
oreo kekse und könnte jetzt entweder zum
beispiel so im ganzen einfach in das
muffin förmchen reinlegen oder ihr macht
sie klein damit ihr einfach so richtig
schöne knusprige stückchen in eurem
muffin mit drin habt und ich mache jetzt
mit dem alligator schneider kennen
ihr könnt sie auch mit den händen
sammeln aber das ist dann ein bisschen
klebrig oder mit einem messer
zerschneiden sieht man mal wie scharf
das ist
und da habt ihr hier diese wunderschönen
kleinen gleichmäßigen würfel und die
gebe ich jetzt hier direkt mit in den
teig und hier einmal unter
und jetzt kann ich den teig mit einem
eis portionierer einfach richtig schön
in die muffin förmchen verteilen
ich habe jetzt hier noch teig für etwa
drei bis vier muffins die befehle ich
jetzt auch gleich noch aber die kommen
jetzt schon mal in den backofen und zwar
bei 170 grad für etwa 20 minuten
am ende werde ich auf jeden fall die
stäbchen probleme und fand woche machen
und lass dir dann erst mal komplett
abkühlen bevor dann später die zehn
braucht kommt meine machen sind jetzt
schön abgekühlt und ich zeige mich jetzt
noch ganz kurz die zutaten für die creme
und dann bereit ein bisschen mit dass
amira zu haben und so also ich habe hier
300 g schlagsahne 300 gramm frischkäse
und hier habe ich zehn oreo keksen dann
brauche ich etwas sonderbar thumm zwar
sechs teelöffel 50 gramm puderzucker und
später für die dekoration habe ich hier
so mini marios und zwar gibt es den so
einem kleinen mix mit so
milka-schokolade stückchen und klar ja
darf steht ein clown waren sowieso 11
ich habe damit gerechnet sind ja davon
darf und ich nehme jetzt da ist die ohre
klicks und zerkleinerte das mache ich
nicht in so einem eps ihr könnt sie aber
zum beispiel auch mit nudelholz in einem
gefrierbeutel zerkleinern
nur müsste dann halt richtig schön klein
machen weil ich sehr gleich mit der
creme vermissen
jetzt sind die jungs richtig schön
zerkleinert die kann ich kurz zur seite
stellen und kann bereits die sahne steif
schlagen und die schlag jetzt erstmal so
10 sekunden und dann gebe ich drei
teelöffel seiner partner dazu
jetzt ist die sahne steif sieht man auch
daran wenn ich die schlüssel umdrehen
dann fällt nicht frau und jetzt kann ich
hier den frischkäse mit puderzucker und
warmer passten da kommen jetzt auch drei
teelöffel rein
es hilft einfach dabei darf die creme
schon fest wird und später eben auch
standfest bleibt wird jetzt auch ohne
funktionieren aber dann bleibt die
premiere nicht so lange stand fest und
so hab da einfach sicherheit dass er
lang genug leben fest dass jetzt einmal
ganz kurz durch bevor ich die kekse mit
dazu gehen
jetzt kommen die kekse mit rein
und jetzt kann ich noch die sahne
unterheben
und jetzt habe ich die fertige krems und
die fülle ich jetzt in einen
spritzbeutel dann nehme ich jetzt ein
einweg spritzbeutel und hab da eine ganz
große loch thüle drauf
und jetzt ist es da oben einfach nur
noch schön verschließen und könnte jetzt
die creme bereits auf die auch die
marines drauf spritzen
und jetzt kommt noch die deko obendrauf
und zwar dieser kleine mini orio den
stecken wir jetzt einfach so seitlich
ein bisschen rein geht der purzel
darunter der muss man bisher einstecken
ok aufholen samira wir noch ein paar
schokostreusel drauf deswegen darf sie
die noch karten
ja wenn man das jetzt zusammen
natürlich schaut man jetzt nehmen wir
einfach so ein paar zucker streusel und
ein paar schokostreusel genau
die cupcakes sind jetzt fertig würde ich
stelle es jetzt ganz kurz in den
kühlschrank in der zwischenzeit kann ich
nämlich schon mal hier schön aufräumen
und samira kann die rechtlichen
schokostreusel hierauf naschen und dann
sehen wir uns gleich wieder hat uns
amira dürfen dann nämlich sofort
probieren durfte doch mit mir zusammen
gemacht nicht probieren wir nehmen die
mit so jetzt dürfen meine zwei probieren
samira nimmt die reine - zu den papa
trägt auch einnehmen martin horat
probieren
oh ja sorry genau tag x weil er ist
jetzt ziemlich viel creme oben drauf
aber wir haben ja auch ziemlich viel
machen da drin
diese förmchen sind jetzt so zum größten
teil mit dem muffin gefüllt und dann
eben noch die creme und deswegen ist es
super wenn man das von oben nach unten
ist dieses stück im dritten sind ja das
war murat didin
ich habe glaube ich den text ganz ramona
hacks da kommt manchmal stückchen näher
sports nicht gelichtet nicht ganz rein
macht wie sie diese stücke würfel dann
hat man immer mal wieder so ein komitee
abgesehen in den fällen in denen kann
man schön backen
man kann da übrigens nicht nur muffins
und cupcakes drin machen man kann die
zweifel auch einfach benutzen um kekse
zu verschenken
also ich hab dir auch in etwas größer da
kann man da so ein süßes kekse schon
rein machen mit bisschen folie einpacken
und man ist auch eine hübsche
geschenkideen
ich glaube den beiden schmeckt's weil
ich beim nächsten mal ein schwätzchen
weil wir es nur um rat machst du kannst
du ein bisschen pinton mir aus karamell
caramel stücke ja wer möchte könnte
jetzt einfach karamell oder was anderes
drauf geben
samira hat sich für die schokostreusel
entschieden und ich finde die passen
auch geschmacklich sehr gut dazu so
schokolade und vanille aber murat
karaman stehen mit rein machen und ihr
dürft das rezept gerne nachlesen auf
sellings okay dann sagte er ich bin da
können dir meine rezepte übrigens auch
ausdrucken oder auch einfach als pdf
abspeichern und ich hoffe euch hat
dieses rezept gefallen und wir sehen uns
dann beim nächsten mal wieder
du hast auch grad nur die creme genießen
so genau so ehrlich wie grace kelly mit
den karamell stücken schmeckt übrigens
noch bis auch noch besser
ok dann probiere ich das auch gleich als
auch bis zum nächsten mal kommen hatte
mich dass so mit dem mit dem muffin und
dann und gott jetzt gruppe